it seems as though Ted lasso has ridden
off into the sunset if the third season
finale really is the end did this show
touted as a champion of kindness give
its characters A fitting send-off Ted
lasso begins with the title character
moving to England to take a job managing
an underdog English football team AFC
Richmond he doesn't know a thing about
soccer but taking the job serves as an
escape he and his wife need some space
as they try to repair their marriage
but you know what I say
what happened that's what I'm doing
though I'm giving you that space lasso
sees the team through brutal losses and
terrific wins relegation and promotion
personal issues and self-discovery
season three sees Ted coming to terms
with the end of his marriage and making
a big decision to maintain a
relationship with his son Henry the
start of the third season also sees
wonderkid Nathan Shelley coaching West
Ham United the former Richmond kit man
grapples with his Newfound
responsibility before quitting and
trying to ReDiscover who he is Roy Kent
also goes on a journey of self-discovery
after a breakup with Keeley and even
coach beard finally spreads his wings
and learns to fly on his own several
players on the team also go through
personal plights as the season
progresses Colin shares his sexual
orientation with the team Jaime learns
how to be a team player and Sam opens
the Nigerian restaurant of his dreams
the apparent series finale sees everyone
coming to terms with Ted's ultimate
decision to leave the team to be with
his family the players and a select
group of fans perform a coordinated
musical number at Ted and Coach Beard's
last practice while Rebecca refuses to
acknowledge Ted's decision until push
comes to shove she threatens to sell the
team if you go IGA AFC Richmond wins a
nail-biting final match against West Ham
but not the Premier League leaving them
without the final feather in their cap
after a disappointing first half the
team reveals they've kept the pieces of
the iconic belief sign which Nate
destroyed back at the end of season 2
piecing it back together everyone else
seems to get a happy ending Roy Kent
becomes the New Richmond manager and
goes to therapy coach beard stays behind
and marries Jane Sam gets to play for
the Nigerian national team Rebecca ends
up selling 49 of the team to the fans
keeping majority ownership while also
having a chance encounter with the man
she met in Amsterdam earlier in the
season Nate finds happiness with his
girlfriend Jade and his family keely's
PR firm is going strong Jaime reconnect
x with his father journalist Trent Crim
publishes his book and Keely and Rebecca
seem prepared to start an AFC Richmond
women's team throughout the series Ted
does what he can to make the lives of
those around him better so when his
marriage fails it's almost impossible
for him to mentally grasp because he
couldn't make Michelle's life better or
keep her happy no matter how hard he
tried season 3 sees Ted learn how to
accept what he can't control and to let
it go especially with help from Rebecca
who went through something similar in
the aftermath of her divorce from Rupert
rather than continue to run away from
what he can't control Ted decides to go
back home to Kansas even if it means he
is returning to an environment that
reminds him of his failure acceptance is
a significant theme across the series
particularly in the final season and not
just for Ted Rebecca accepts that there
is nothing she did to cause her
ex-husband Rupert to cheat on her with
younger women it's something he will
always do no matter how young or perfect
his wife is she also has to accept that
her marriage prevented her from doing
some things in her life she goes to a
fertility specialist early in the season
and discovers you can no longer have
biological children forcing her to come
to terms with the loss of that
possibility season 3 also puts a
spotlight on Colin who's closeted and
worried about coming out to the other
players on the team when Trent
unknowingly comes across Colin kissing
his partner he provides a helpful ear as
Colin struggles with revealing his
sexuality Colin's best friend Isaac
later looks at Colin's texts and finds
messages to his boyfriend after some
initial anger Isaac tries to understand
and accept why his friend didn't come
out to him he eventually confronts Colin
at his home asking if he had done
something to make his friend think he
wouldn't accept him when Colin's ready
Isaac and the team readily support him
he's a fitness guy on the team I won't
tell him and you'd never guess
I guess Bumble catch yes
while AFC Richmond has always seemed
like a tight-knit group of friends there
were conflicts for example Jaime was a
ball hog on the pitch often refusing to
pass with his Sunny disposition and
unconventional methods Ted changes that
over his three years with the team he
encourages them to be honest and open to
support one another on and off the field
and to reflect on how they can improve
themselves he even gives them each a
book that he thinks will help them on
their Journeys to self-discovery by the
end of the series Ted has cultivated
teammates that are fiercely loyal to one
another a prime example from season 3 is
when Sam's Restaurant is vandalized
after a public argument with the
politician the team bands together to
repair the damage Ted takes a team and
turns them into a family this is
undoubtedly a major theme of the entire
series men's mental health is often a
stigmatized topic but Ted lasso doesn't
Flinch away from the issue characters
take the time to reflect on themselves
and what they need to maintain their
mental well-being a prime example is how
Roy initially reacts to Trent's presence
during the season the journalist a
fairly scathing review of Roy after his
first professional game which is haunted
Roy for decades not only does Roy come
to accept that it wasn't a personal dig
but he also starts to understand how it
impacted his mindset in his career and
personal life and breaking up with
Keeley Roy realizes he needs to work on
himself though he waits until the end of
the season to really take those steps
the season also has what is a sometimes
difficult to watch breakdown on Jaime's
part he clearly has a significant amount
of weight on his shoulders as the season
progresses especially as the team begins
to soar this results in a sobbing fit in
the locker room before a key game rather
than allow himself to bottle it up he
lets it out in front of Roy who in the
past probably would have ridiculed him
for it and makes a point to go and visit
the person in his life who always makes
him feel better his mom
the third season of Ted lasso is filled
with turbulence but everyone lands
safely in the end many of the characters
get what they've wanted throughout the
season whether it be more time with
their family or the chance to play for
their dream team some like Roy and Jaime
have what they need rather than what
they want which is to be with Keeley
some critics and viewers may think it's
unrealistic for everyone to be in such
good places in the end but it reinforces
what audiences have come to know and
love about the series we get what we
give back to the world the only person
in a negative place is Rupert II after
being the leading antagonist for the
entirety of the series has fallen from
Grace after his new ex-wife and
assistant speak out against him the
people who put in the work are in a
better place now which is alt had wanted
for them when he met them three years
ago he made a lasting impact that has
helped the people in his life discover
new things about themselves including
what brings them fulfillment thank you
oh sorry nope please go first the ending
of Ted lasso seems to wrap most things
up with a bow almost too neatly
According to some fans and critics the
Montage of everyone's happy ending plays
out on screen only for the next cut to
be Ted waking up on the airplane landing
back in the United States for the first
time since leaving for England this has
caused fans to question whether the
Happy Endings we see are actually Ted's
dreams there is an argument to be made
that what we are seeing is what Ted
wants for them and not what actually
happens Ted isn't present during the
wedding sequence which seems odd
considering how close he and Coach beard
are wouldn't he fly back to see his best
friend get married in front of
Stonehenge in a Reddit AMA Brendan hunt
who plays beard and co-created the
series had an answer when asked if the
wedding is real or in Ted's mind hunt
simply replied real but then fans wanted
to know why Ted wasn't at coach Beard's
wedding hunt explains that the
character's friendship has had periods
of not seeing each other and he expects
that the future we're seeing falls into
that he also argued the reasoning is
narrative and it would be anti-climactic
dick and deflating if we suddenly see
him back there before we even see his
plane land
the creators and cast of Ted lasso have
been upfront about the future of the
series or lack thereof in an interview
with deadline Jason Sudeikis who
co-created the show and placed Ted made
it pretty clear saying this is the end
of this story that we wanted to tell
that we were hoping to tell that we
loved to tell there's a lot of things we
don't get in life that we want but you
know it's the journey to get there so I
have to get kind of done with this
chapter fans have known that the series
was designed for three seasons for quite
some time particularly after Brett
Goldstein who plays Roy Kent and is a
writer on the show confirms the
designated end in 2022 to variety
stating it was planned as three in his
Reddit AMA Brendan hunt expressed that
nothing is set in stone at the moment
but the creative team needs to rest
before they talk about the future of the
series and characters he explained we
don't know we need a break and we'll
take one presently nothing has been
ruled out everything is possible but
that includes the possibility that we're
done we won't know until we've sat with
it for a while decompressed Etc even
though the series is likely over the
team isn't writing off the possibility
of developing a spin-off series or two
sudakis told deadline that spin-offs
were still on the table saying I think
that we've set the table for all sorts
of folks to get to watch the further
telling of these stories hunt reaffirmed
the chance of a spin-off in his Reddit
AMA confirming that discussions still
need to happen after a well-deserved
break when asked about the chance of a
spin-off about the AFC Richmond women's
team Keeley and Rebecca plan in the
finale Juno Temple who plays Keeley
didn't rule it out in an interview with
deadline she noted that the series
showcases female friendships adding it
would be amazing to see how they would
continue to do wonderful things together
Hannah wadingham who plays Rebecca
echoed Temple's thoughts in her own
interview with deadline commenting I
love the Arc of keeley's character to
present something to Rebecca that she
hasn't thought about also in an
interview with deadline Phil dunster who
plays Jaime offered the view that it's
alright if this is the end saying I
would love for there to be more but also
if that's all she wrote Let It Be
as far as we know right now the third
season of Ted lasso is indeed the end as
the end of a series it provides closure
for most of the story lines fans dug
into over the span of 34 episodes from
Ted learning to accept what he can't
change to Roy realizing he needs to grow
for himself and himself alone the team
comes out on the other side of their
time with Ted with a new perspective on
life and memories that will last forever
the end of Ted lasso also means the end
to some important on-screen
representation of men's mental health
from Ted's panic attacks to Nate's
implied depression after quitting his
dream job in turn the series also shows
its characters doing the work to better
themselves by going to therapy something
that is still stigmatized in many places
today hopefully Ted lasso will always be
available to watch on Apple TV plus
helping break the stigma for new
audiences for years to come
hello
[Music]